Tucker Carlson is defending rioters in
Brazil and baselessly claiming that the
Brazilian election was quote rigged I
don't think this will come as a shock to
many of you Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson
who has taken very strange positions on
Russia's invasion of Ukraine who has
taken very strange positions on
everything from free speech to terrorism
over the years you know he says flat out
the election in Brazil was rigged and
then he uses that to justify and defend
the rioting that we are seeing in the
Trump riots Brazil version that we
talked about yesterday let's listen
thanks to what was very clearly a rigged
election a convicted criminal called
Lula de Silva is now the president of
the most important country in South
America
millions of people in Brazil understand
exactly what happened they know that
their democracy has been hijacked
possibly forever
but there's not much they can do about
that Lulu may be a criminal in fact he
is but he has the full support of both
the bid Administration and the Chinese
government well he won
that's an important detail he won
so yesterday in frustration a group of
Brazilian protesters swarmed their
legislature watch thanks to what was
very so then then he shows the video
um Tucker Carlson then goes on to say
that what happened in Brazil is being
likened to January 6 but that that is
very much not the case let's take a
listen to this you may actually have
seen some of that video in the United
States over the last couple of days and
you saw it because it has political uses
what's happened in Brazil is being
likened to January 6th and of course
populist leaders in this country are
being blamed for it oh it was Trump and
Steve Bannon who did it that's not true
but even if it were true it would be
just the tail end of the story it would
be the result of something that happened
before
so the obvious question is why are
protesters in Brazil so angry right well
they're angry because the new Lula
government has eliminated their most
basic civil liberties
Lula is working to turn Brazil into a
chinese-style dictatorship and he's
doing it very quickly with maximum
aggression what and our media don't want
to talk about that because it's not true
refuse to why well for reasons that
should make you very nervous yeah listen
I'm it's it's incredible when the right
becomes so extreme and unhinged that I
end up doing the strangest things on the
show and what I mean by that is I'm no
fan of Lula politically in the sense
that of course if I was in Brazil and my
choices were Lula and bolsonaro I vote
Lula but I've told you Lula is in the
mold of this sort of
populist rhetoric kinda corrupt uh in in
the vein of some other South American
leaders where he's better than bolsonaro
but it's not like I go wow this is
someone I really really think is a
absolutely fantastic person but if I'm
on the side of the rule of law there is
no option here but to defend the legal
basis for Lula's win period to defend
the legal basis for Lula being the
president and to unanimously and and
categorically condemn what is happening
in Brazil and a similar attempt to what
we saw in the United States because at
the end of the day Tucker says well it's
different
it's different in that the mass arrests
of the rioters seem to have started more
quickly that's that's good
it's different in that it's happening
after the inauguration rather than
before that that's true it's different
in that the guy they're rioting on the
behalf of bolsonaro is in Orlando in a
hospital after going to KFC in a Publix
that's different okay than what Trump
was up to on on the day of the Trump
riots but it is the same in the sense
that people are destroying property and
being violent and trying to overwhelm
police because they want a candidate
that lost to be the president that's the
exact same thing Brazil counted all of
its votes in hours just the way Maga
wants the United States to do they did
it in Brazil but still they say it was
fraudulent Brazil's military found no
fraud in the election and then they say
well they but they didn't rule out the
fraud well what exactly do you mean by
that they didn't rule it but they didn't
find any oh no no they but that that's
that's weird language uh it is indeed
the same thing in terms of its
motivations and at this point
should we even be surprised that we are
seeing Tucker defend the rioters I say
no we'll have these clips on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David packman
show and please make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below